organiser un dîner vendredi simon
voulait venir voir la tête et d'insister
d'ailleurs je lui le proposait d'être se
parle on avait dit pas ne pas rater
quand on doit voir papa t'es content
c'est un bon plan de carrière sa samba
qui abattront dit n'étant pas un
symbolique je n'ai pas tant parlé au
téléphone mais quoi ça c'est mon père
c'est peut-être la dernière occasion de
passer une soirée avec les ibères je
sais que ça m'aurait fait plaisir qu'on
soit tous réunis et sans toi je me
libère
bien sûr alors obligatoire la maison
[Musique]
tiens c'est pour toi essayer enfin ça
fait dix ans qu'il arrêtait de fumer
tu sais c'est pas bon pour ses artères
et alors quelle importance maman t'as vu
ma petite fille haidar peut la voir tout
ce monde
j syndicats les petites années me donne
quand même voiture at elle ajouté à son
bichon en fait je n'ai pas remarqué la
même temps je me sens que sa mère est un
bon pourquoi elle est une tache de
naissance et non pas dans le coup mais
où un resto et sept îles a déglingué
mais je te fous
elle est magnifique